[Music]
well then who left this here yeah where
did this come from who is leaving dishes
boys on your bed go get dressed
[Music]
[Music]
Luke if you ever loved me if you love me
please get the boys to stop making
messes and to clean up boys your mother
is very upset with you
you guys better start cleaning up all
your messes right now
listen boys we're either gonna do this
the easy way or the hard way think
really carefully about your next move
back down baddest two of us I got two
guns and there's two of you boys good
but not that good
what's it gonna be you're gonna clean or
you get filled full of foam
[Music]
we need to do something drastic
you're the best machine gun ever it's a
parent detector it tells me how far away
dad is fifty feet ten feet five feet
that thing must be plugging he should be
in the womb by now
[Music]
Tommy we need to make some booby traps
but how are we gonna make the meliss
ikanaide what how did you get the freaky
grenade
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh free fishing here my day is looking
better already
oh that looks like the nude I am cast
you're gonna pay little boogers you shot
your dad in the bud hey boys it's your
father
[Applause]
[Music]
Luke boys are you guys making a mess
everybody's destroyed the house
[Music]
[Music]
come on come on Tommy see behind us here
all right guys we got some time let's
call 9-1-1 oh yeah yes oh hello it's
Mother's Day and we forgot to clean and
my wife's trying to murder us all yes I
said we forgot to clean the house for
Mother's Day and we kind of made a huge
mess and now my wife's trying to kill us
all if you liked this video don't forget
to check out the outdoor boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like that and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos ever
and hit that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
okay hi baby